Bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados el 30 de octubre los
brasileños acudirán a la segunda Ronda
de las elecciones presidenciales para
elegir entre el izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva y el
ultraconservador Yair bolsonaro el nuevo
presidente hará frente a múltiples retos
en el país a continuación les explicamos
algunos de los principales polarización
la primera vuelta de los comicios
evidenció una profunda división en el
país solo 5 puntos en la votación
separaron al actual presidente bolsonaro
de Lula da Silva pero el apoyo que
recibieron es casi proporcional al
rechazo que existe hacia ambos según la
encuesta de datafolia realizada tras la
primera ronda un 51% de la población
asegura que no votaría por el líder
ultraconservador y un 46%, no lo haría
por Lula da Silva el rechazo al ex
presidente Lula se debe en gran parte al
recelo a su partido de los trabajadores
al que una buena parte de la población
escándalos de corrupción como el sonado
caso la bayato mientras otro sector
poblacional se opone a bolsonaro que sea
caracterizado por un discurso
incendiario misógeno y machista el
mandatario ha cuestionado al congreso al
poder judicial y al sistema electoral
también ha impulsado con decenas de
decretos el uso de armas de fuego y
propiciado la deforestación de la
amazonía a favor de sectores como el
agroindustrial y la minería ilegal
además fue acusado por crímenes contra
la humanidad por su gestión de la
pandemia al minimizar desde su inicio su
impacto y negarse a implantar medidas
para prevenir el contagio su gestión
mantuvo durante meses a Brasil como uno
de los países más afectados por el
coronavirus en el mundo violencia
política otro reflejo de la polarización
es la violencia política que ha
convulsionado la campaña electoral en
los últimos meses varios ataques entre
evolucionaristas ilulistas han dejado
personas muertas el temor de convertirse
en víctima se ha extendido
un sondeo reciente de datafoliá indico
que el 67,5% de los brasileños tema de
ser agredido por su posición política
mientras que un 3,2% dijo ya haber
recibido amenazas de acuerdo a un
estudio de las organizaciones justicia
global y tierra de derechos la violencia
política en el país aumentó en un 400%
en 2022 en relación a 2018 y los
miembros del partido de los trabajadores
fueron las principales víctimas del 2 de
septiembre al 2 de octubre de este año
se registraron
523 episodios de violencia 54 asesinatos
109 ataques a personas del común y 151
ataques a líderes políticos o asesores
todo ello en medio de un gobierno que ha
facilitado el porte de armas en el país
se adquieren unas 1300 diariamente y
Esto llevó a un juez a suspender los
decretos de armas emitidos por bolsonaro
ante el de violencia política en el
contexto electoral paradójicamente en
términos generales en 2021 hubo 41,069
asesinatos en Brasil un mínimo en 15
años según datos oficiales sin embargo
el país Sigue estando entre los 10 con
tasas de homicidios más altas del mundo
de acuerdo a datos de Naciones Unidas
hambre y pobreza es quizás el reto más
titánico que enfrenta el próximo
presidente actualmente en Brasil unos 33
millones de brasileños pasan hambre
según datos oficiales eso supone Un
aumento del 7,2% desde 2020 y significa
que 14 millones de personas más están en
esa situación en números absolutos hay
unos 125 millones de brasileños que han
experimentado algún grado de inseguridad
alimentaria Brasil había salido del mapa
del hambre de Naciones Unidas en 2014
pero ahora vuelve a formar parte de él
técnicamente en términos de hambre el
país Tropical ha retrocedido a niveles
de 1990
el desempleo es una de sus principales
causas con 11 millones de personas sin
trabajo en la nación la falta de
oportunidades laborales también ha hecho
crecer el número de personas sin hogar
en 2012 el país contabilizaba 92.550
personas sin techo y en 2020 ya eran
222,000 medio ambiente Brasil también
enfrenta el desafío inmediato de detener
la deforestación los llamados
internacionales y nacionales se hacen
cada vez más urgentes para proteger a la
selva amazónica vital para contrarrestar
los efectos del cambio climático la
deforestación se ha disparado en los
últimos años por diversos motivos como
la tala ilegal la expansión de la
agroindustria la organización y la
minería de acuerdo al ente gubernamental
encargado de monitorear la deforestación
el Instituto Nacional de pesquisas
espaciales de Brasil para 2020 y desde
1988 se habían deforestado 729 mil
kilómetros cuadrados de la amazonía
legal un 17% del ecosistema tanto en los
gobiernos de Lula da Silva de 2003 a
2011 como en el de bolsonaro se
produjeron afectaciones a la amazonía en
cifras alarmantes pero durante el
mandato del ultraconservador se han
batido récords históricos con más de
10.000 hectáreas deforestadas de media
en los últimos dos años según el fondo
mundial para la naturaleza desde 2019
hasta Julio de 2022 el territorio
deforestado en la amazonía equivale al
tamaño de Bélgica todos estos desafíos
se enfrenta quien tome las riendas del
país el próximo primero de enero y lo
hará en medio de un contexto
internacional complejo marcado por la
guerra en Ucrania los estragos de una
pandemia que ha matado en la nación a
más de 680 mil personas y una inflación
interanual para septiembre del 7%. si
les sirvió el vídeo para entender los
desafíos que enfrenta Brasil en los
próximos años los esperamos en otro
episodio de en 5 minutos en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]